welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and let's talk
about the big bads of stranger things
although the mind flayer hasn't
physically appeared in volume 4 yet both
he and becna seem to be carrying out the
same plan to take over the right side up
and wipe out the inferior human life
dustin calls vechna the mindflayer's
five-star general but why is that the
case why would this psionic force team
up with vecna instead of simply
incorporating him into its hive mind
well i've got a theory and it has to do
with the mind flare's potential true
form but first let's go over everything
we know about the two biggest baddies
we've seen throughout the series bethna
and the mind player bekna aka one aka
henry creel is a human-turned lich who
became disillusioned with the rules and
structure imposed on him by society in
the human realm his only desire is to
restore balance to the world by wiping
out mediocrity and believes that eleven
is powerful enough to help him make that
happen in order to attack his victims
fekna plugs himself into several
tentacles giving him the ability to
infiltrate teenage dreams above from his
lair below he has a deep love and
reverence for spiders and the mind
player itself even looks like a giant
spider so it's also possible that the
flare is exploiting this to sway vechna
under its control unlike the mind flayer
however vechna isn't using anyone on
earth as a proxy or host he is doing
this thing freddy krueger boiler room
style the mind player is a shadowy
psychic being without physical form
instead it manipulates lesser beings to
do its bidding including demogorgons
demma dogs and the flayed when it
evacuated will's uninhabitable heated
body a dark mist escaped but became
dormant as soon as the psychic
connection between hawkins and the
upside down severed when elle closed the
gate when the gate was reopened by the
russians in season 3 it began building a
physical body to act as a proxy in our
world his psychic abilities alone
weren't enough to stop her in the past
so this time he's sending a
representative speaking through billy
the mind player tells 11 that he built
it just for her and that all of the pain
and suffering it cost was all to kill
her in the end he tells her that once
she's dead and out of the way he'll move
on to ending her friends and after that
he'll end everything this tells me that
the mind flayer knows how powerful l is
and that he needs to eliminate her first
to make his multiversal conquest easier
i think it's possible that the mind
flayer knows about l not only through
personal interactions but through one's
memories of her practicality and style
don't have to be mutually exclusive just
because you want to keep your feet nice
and dry in all kinds of weather doesn't
mean you have to wear some monstrous
rain boots every day bessie's here to
keep you looking good while keeping your
feet dry thanks to bessie for sponsoring
this video besties are the perfect
everyday shoe they're sustainably made
knit sneakers that are a hundred percent
waterproof they're made with this
dimetex material that's super easy to
clean with just a rinse of water oh no
i spilled water all over my feetsy
wheatsies but my oinky oinkies are bone
dry like the dune sea thanks bessie if
you're experiencing wet or muddy weather
right now bessies can help slay soggy
socks forever that's these are my go-to
shoes by my door check them out in the
link below for a pair of your own bessie
shoes click the link below and use new
rock stars to get 25 off your vessy
shoes it's established that all of these
monsters in the upside down are
connected by a giant hive mind and that
it operates like a virus spreading
quickly and coming back stronger and
smarter after each time it's killed this
season vecna is opening multiple portals
to the upside down and i believe that
his goal is to create more gates than 11
could reasonably close scaling up for an
invasion dr owens adamantly tells 11
that her friends in hawkins aren't the
only ones in danger if the creatures in
the upside down successfully infiltrate
our reality life as we know it is over
if eleven doesn't hit the mind flare and
vechna so hard that they can't get back
up as the virus-like nature of this
realm and its creatures will surely
spread much farther than the county
lines of a small town in indiana as long
as there's a gate open there's a chance
that our world will face a war they
couldn't win if they tried against
beings far stronger than any earthly
weapons we have in order to completely
take control of the right side up i
think it's possible that we could see
the mind flayer and bekna pull a fusion
and i think that this new villainous
creature might be the elder brain as we
all know the hellfire club formerly
known as the party uses dungeons and
dragons as a lens with which to view the
horrors happening just beneath their
feet people can get hung up on the fact
that stranger things as demogorgon isn't
anything like d d's demogorgon as if
that's a failure in adapting d d
material it isn't the language of d d in
the monster manual is a shorthand the
boys on bikes used to understand this
otherworldly chaos spilling into their
lives that said while these monsters
don't necessarily have every single
characteristic or quality that their dnd
counterparts have most of their
namesakes capture the essence of their
abilities and motivations for example
the mind flayer and vechna both act as
if human life is inferior to them a
trait that these guys have in dnd lore
more importantly mind flayers are
psionic creatures bent on conquering not
just the universe but the multiverse
something we see throughout the series
is the mind flayer tries to add our
world to its collection despite knowing
that not every piece of dungeons and
dragon's lore applies to this specific
show i've always wondered why we've only
seen the one mind flayer traditionally
mind flayers operating colonies sure
they exist more as a race of drones that
share a hive of consciousness while the
duffer brothers mind flayer is a hive
consciousness but where does that
consciousness originate from is it
purely untethered psionic energy or does
it have a source because everything in
the upside down is psychically connected
i think it's entirely possible that the
vines we see are part of that source the
mind flayer's mostly dormant true
physical form the elder brain in dnd the
central hub of these mind flare colonies
is a being called the elder brain a
massive brain that acts as a sort of
queen bee to the mind player's hive mind
it holds intense psychic power but is
relatively vulnerable to physical
attacks that get past all of its psychic
defenses mind flayers within the colony
speak with the elder brain
telepathically and follow its orders and
on rare occasions a mind flayer can
perform a ritual to become an elder
brain now i've always wondered what if
anything those vines in the upside down
are physically connected to the spider
monster that the mind flayer created out
of melted down people pieces also had
these tentacles which plugged themselves
into billy at the end of the battle like
he was the only phone charging station
at a music festival this season vecna
seems to use them as actual power cables
when he connects to the vines in his
upside down layer he's able to boost his
psychic connection to his victims on the
other side which he's not able to do if
he isn't hooked up i think that these
tentacles could be attached to the
upside down's elder brain bestowing
vechna with stronger powers so that mind
flayers can clear a path for destruction
not only do images of the brain from the
monster manual i cuddle up with every
night feature images that show similar
looking tentacles protruding from it it
would make sense that these vines give
vecna and the mind flayer the ability to
contact and possess their victims the
elder brain itself is the mind flayer's
core in the upside down and to conquer
our realm it may need another brain for
our world a hub for psychic connection
that won't be severed by future portals
closing we know that vecna has been
incorporating his victim's psyche into
his own suggesting that he himself is
building a sort of hive consciousness
sort of like a baby mind player so like
the mind flayers that become elder
brains in d and d lore vecna is the
perfect candidate for a potential elder
brain node in the right side up this
might be why vechna hasn't been
incorporated within the mindflayer's
hivemind yet because it might need to
reinforce vecna's psyche with the minds
of others strengthening it in order to
build an organic connection to our world
that won't burn out if all the portals
closed i don't know all the kids are
gonna solve it if this is the case but
that's not my problem follow me on
instagram and twitter whitney puppy
follow new rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you